monieur bonjour bonjour bonjour Jérôme
Durin président de cette commission
d'enquête sur le narcotrafic et
accompagné de d'Étienne BLANC rapporteur
et des administrateurs
qui nous accompagne dans ce travail
merci d'avoir accepté cette audition je
dois excuser d'autres membres de la
commission qui ne sont pas avec nous
aujourd'hui notamment Catherine Conconne
qui a souhaité manifester
euh le les excuses pour son absence
aujourd'hui elle pouvait pas être avec
nous euh je vais devoir
euh procéder à euh vous faire procéder à
une prestation de serment puisque vous
savez qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête est passible des
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal et donc je vais
vous inviter chacun d'entre vous à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité à lever la main
droite et à dire je le
jure
je et Monsieur sapotil Je et ça marche
même à distance merci beaucoup
messieurs du coup je propose que
peut-être
vous nous disiez ce que vous
avez à nous dire sur le sujet puis après
on procédera peut-être une série de
question
réponse qui
commence je te laisse
commencer je suis très embêté parce que
j'ai je ne sais pas ce que j'ai à vous
dire ce que ce qu'on va demander
peut-être c'est que monsieur courtois
désactive son micro pendant qu'il ne
parle pas est-ce qu'on a le bruit de
fond et on vous entendra mieux
merci je je disais que je sais pas quoi
vous dire parce que je
je en lien avec le narcotrafic moi j'y
connais absolument rien et je suis
simplement j'ai accepté de de participer
à à
l'audition de manière à ce que je sache
exactement en tout cas si vous avez des
questions moi en tout cas je suis prêt à
y répondre mais pour ce qui concerne une
connaissance ou pas surrafique moi j
connais absolument
rien on va pouvoir débuter en vous
posant dans déjà directement des des
questions vous êtes maire et en cette
qualité vous avez un contact direct bien
évidemment avec toute une série de
conséquences du narcotrafic et c'est sur
ces conséquences que nous voudrions vous
entendre conséquences pour les familles
conséquences pour un certain nombre de
jeunes conséquences pour le
fonctionnement de quartier conséquence
sur
un problème que nous connaissons de plus
en plus qui est un problème de
corruption corruption d'un certain
nombre de services par le produit du
narcotrafic alors de manière générale
comment est-ce que vous ressentez ces
ces conséquences pour votre commune
est-ce que vous pourriez nous les
détailler de remettre mon
micro en je ne sais pas si ce que je
vais dire est en lien avec la le la
réalité que l'on vit à la Martinique je
pense que Catherine concon qui est
sénatrice a dû largement discuter et en
parler avec vous mais aujourd'hui dans
les territoires d'outr mer je ne sais
pas si vous avez je pense que vous avez
les chiffres de la catastrophe que cela
représente pour nos territoires du des
des saisies importantes de de de de
cocaïne qui se font dans le territoire
donc là on n'est pas en kilo on est en
tonne euh sur ma ville particulièrement
euh il y a pas très longtemps la semaine
il y a à peu près 2 semaines de ça il y
a eu le démantellement d'un réseau mais
là on n'est pas s de la cocaïne on était
sur plutôt de la je dirais du du de la
mariguana ou des choses un peu moins
moins violentes moi je pense que à
Martinique il y a urgence pour que les
frontières pour que les sorties les
rentrées les traversé se fassent en tout
cas soit mieux surveillé je sais qu'il y
a des choses qui sont préparation
notamment pour observer les allés venus
les vaillviens qui se font dans la mer
des Caraïbes en sortant du Venezuela de
la colonbie et qui inombe parfois le le
territoire martiniquis et et mais avec
une destination qui est plutôt une
destination Europe voilà donc c'est que
les les moyens qui sont aujourd'hui
déployés soient renforcés que la
Martinique ne soit pas la plaque
tournante de ou la plaque passante vers
les les pays ou o on consomme à grande
échelle ces produits et puis la dernière
chose c'est que au trafic de au
narcotrafic vient se rajoutter le trafic
des armes euh qui vient également
malheureusement inonder nos territoires
et vous avez un peu à l'image de ce qui
se passe sur les territoires comme
Marseille ou ailleurs des fusillades des
des des des exécutions euh euh quasiment
presque tous les weekends moi je pense
que là oui il y a une urgence à ce que
les je dirais qu'il y ait moyens
supplémentairire qui soit mis pour
mettre à terme à la fois à la traversée
vers les pays d'Europe et puis faire en
sorte que la Martinique et je pense que
les collègues vont vont dire la même
chose qu'on ne fera pas une passoire
pour je dirais tous les produits qui
traversent et les armes en particulier
qui inonde aujourd'hui le territoire
martinquain vous êtes président de
l'association des mires et de la
Martinique
et est-ce
que ce que vous nous dites est ressenti
par l'ensemble des mir est-ce que vous
constatez des différence de degré
et en fonction de la nature des
différentes communes dont vous assurer
la présidence oou est-ce que vous
constatez que désormais les secteurs
urbains les secteurs moins urbanisés les
secteurs touristiques comme les secteurs
moins touristiques sont frappés par le
même
phénomène ça vous savez c'est toute
l'île qui est touchée du nord au sud
euh avec j'ai parlé donc de de narcrafic
j'ai parlé du trafic des armes et je
viens y rajouter l'immigration
clandestine et qui vient euh je dirais
renforcer un sentiment qui est un
sentiment partagé par tous et et et
l'actualité si elle est comment vous
dire favorable aux autorités qui
précisent avoir capturé saisi des tonn
relativement importante pour nous de là
où on est on est plutôt inquiet quand on
voit le le le le le volume de ce qui est
saisi et et je ne parle pas de ce qu'on
de ce qu'on ne sait pas mais je parle de
ce que de ce qui fait l'actualité de ce
qui est de l'information que l'on reçoit
de manière un peu brutale comme tout le
monde de d'une saisie de 10 kg de 3 kg
et je vous parle pas des armes les armes
aujourd'hui on ne on ne nous parle pas
de saisie d'armes par contre on vit
l'utilisation de ces armes de manière
extrêmement violente des martiniquain
entre eux et puis évidemment des
exécutions qui peuTent se faire sur le
territoire tous les maires de Martinique
vivent cette situation de manière
stressante
et la population d'ailleurs nous demande
ce que nous faisons mais écoutez moi je
quand je quand cette question m'est
posée moi j'ai pas de réponse comment un
maire aujourd'hui peut intervenir dans
ce champ et faire en sorte de faire
cesser le trafic d'armes trafic de
drogue à une échelle qui est une échelle
qui n'est plus une échelle locale mais
une échelle internationale voilà donc je
je je pense que je l'ai dit au début de
mes propos il y a des choses qui
dépassent simplement le je dirais le le
cadre de ce que un maire peut faire et
là on est dans du grand banditisme et ça
ça appelle des moyens qui sont des
moyens à la hauteur d'une situation qui
est pour moi aujourd'hui une situation
catastrophique et merci
et vous venez de le dire euh ça n'est
pas le rôle des maires que de poursuivre
que de lancer des procédures en revanche
les maires sont en contact avec les
différents services d'état qui sont en
charge de lutter contre ce fléo comment
est-ce que vous jugez vos contacts avec
ces différents services est-ce qu'ils
sont faciles vous les estimez suffisants
quand vous faites remonter les
informations quand vous avez une
sollicitation est-ce que vous avez un
retour est-ce qu'il y a des réponses qui
sont des réponses positives est-ce que
vous ressentez quand quand vous
saisissez les services de l'État un
résultat suite à leur
intervention alors je vais vous répondre
très directement sur le le sur le
narcotrafic zéro information nous sommes
comme je suis un citoyen lambda je
découvre devant ma télé qu'il y a des
saisies ou des des interpellations de
trafiquants sur le territoire ça c'est
une première chose par contre sur les
petits trafics le petit larsin quand
nous quand nous nous informons les
autorités euh pareil il y a une vraie
comment vous dire je je ne sais que
réseau et démantelé que quand il est et
alors que nous moi j'apporte
régulièrement de l'information de ce que
je vois de ce que je sais de là où je
pense qu'il y a effectivement matière à
à observation ou à ou à
interpellation mais je ne sais que les
choses se font que quand elles sont
faites et il n'y a pas si vous voulez
une une régularité deun retour de
formation en lien avec de je dirais de
l'information que j'aurais donné
moi-même et ce que je vous dis là c'est
assez ce sont des discussions qu'on a
régulièrement avec les services pour
leur dire de la même manière que nous
nous sommes en capacité de vous donner
des informations prévenez-nous c'est pas
parce que nous avons besoin plus que
cela moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
les réseaux soient démantelés pour le
reste sur les grosses opérations euh moi
je découvre ces grosses opérations à la
télé comme tout le monde et et et
malheureusement euh quand la population
nous pose des questions quand la
population nous interroge sur euh euh la
connaissance que nous avons de ces
éléments d' on en a pas maintenant je
vais vous dire très honnêtement
euh les relations sont bonnes avec la
gendarmerie puisque je suis en zone en
zone gendarmerie il y a d'excellentes
relations euh et depuis quelques temps
j'ai
constaté sur des opérations qui sont
programmées euh les la la compagnie
gendarmerie me donne l'information un
peu en amont parfois mais globalement
sur les opérations qui sont des
opérations de trafic de trafic d'armes
ou d'interpellation de voyou dans la
ville je découvre ça le lendemain une
fois que c'est
fait bien de manière
générale comment est-ce que vous jugez
la réponse pénale
et par la justice vous est suffisante
suffisamment efficace suffisamment
rapide suffisamment forte pour lutter
contre ce
fléo pas assez rapide et trop douce
parce Queen réalité vous avez des
personnes qui sont interpellées et ben
je vous donner l'exemple de ce qui s'est
passé dans ma vie il y a à peu près 2
semaines les mêmes il y a eu un tapage
médiatique disant que il y avait un
réseau de trafiquants qui avaient été
démantelés dans ma ville le lendemain
tous ceux qui étaient en garde à vue je
les ai retrouvé dans la rue ils étaient
tranquillement après leur garde à vue
dans la rue il y en a il y en a même un
qui est venu me demander du boulot je
suppose que ça participait à à ce que ça
pouvait éventuellement réduire sa peine
ou éviter qu'il rentre en
prison 2 48 he après celui qui avait été
un garde à vue était dans la mairie me
demandant est-ce que je pouvais
éventuellement le lui donner du travail
donc les réponses sont parfois trop
douce les procédures sont trop lentes et
vous avez des personnes qui face à à des
situations où elles sont en fait limite
euh comment vous dire dans une sorte
d'impunité ben vont recommencer parce
que aux yeux de la population si on les
a interpellé que le lendemain ou le
surlendemain ils sont dans la rue ça
veut dire que potentiellement ça n'était
peut-être pas quelque chose de grave
mais on sait bien vous comme moi que les
procédures étant longues ce sont des
personnes qui tôt ou tard vont se
retrouver effectivement en situation
d'enfermement ou en prison mais ça prend
trop de temps parce que les gens ont
besoin immédiatement que ces personnes
soient écartées de l'espace qui est un
espace collectif où il y a un risque
pour tous parce que ce sont des
personnes qui sont dans du trafic à la
fois visible aux yeux de tous et qui dit
trafic dit derrière de la violence
physique pour ceux qui vivent dans leur
environnement on connaît
aujourd'hui un développement du d'une
corruption il y a une corruption qui est
une corruption de très haute intensité
que l'on voit dans dans des
services sur le
continent des affaires de de corruption
qui sont des affaires l et puis on
constate aussi une corruption que l'on
appelle corruption de basse intensité
pour faciliter du trafic pour faciliter
le deal bien on va se rapprocher ici
d'un service administratif ici d'une
municipalité et de ses services est-ce
que vous avez connaissance de phénomène
de cette nature en Martinique est-ce que
les maires vous font remonter les
informations au moins sur un risque
qu'ils peuvent
encourir au regard de de de cette
corruption qui se
développe je vais vous répondre
directement non du tout j'ai jamais eu à
à connaître de ce genre de chose
peut-être j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas pour ce qui me concerne jamais j'ai
jamais entendu parler de ce genre de
chose jamais très bien merci et puis
dernière question est-ce que vous pouvez
nous formuler quelques suggestions pour
nous dire voilà pour améliorer la lutte
contre le
narcotrafic que ce soit la lutte contre
le deal ce trafic est un trafic de base
et puis le trafic plus élevé vous
connaissez vous l'avez très bien dit sur
vos côtes venant du Venezuela ou
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez quelques
suggestions quelques pistes que vous
pourriez nous
donner il y a une piste hein elle est
simple mais je je sais que ça va c'est
c'est un moyen qui revient souvent ce
sont les moyens les moyens humains faire
en sorte que sur le le terrain qu'il y
ait des des forces présentes et qui à la
fois contrôle les frontières s'assure
qu'on qu'on ne soit pas dans une île
passoire et que le le la traversée de la
Martinie ne soit pas simplement une
traversée vers d'autres destinations ça
c'est une première chose la seconde
chose il y a quelque chose qui a été qui
s'est réalisé il y a quelques temps
c'est qu'on a eu des forces de
gendarmerie supplémentaires environ 80
gendarmes on a vu les résultats de la
présence de ces gendarmes sur le terrain
euh et et les dealers les
voyou SAV pertinemment que quand il y a
effectivement des forces de l'ordre qui
sont présentes ben le il y a un
ralentissement et une une une position
qui est une position plus je dirais de
leur part qui est un peu plus feutré
caché et puis des interventions musclées
parfois sur des sur des lieux qui sont
des lieux a priori qui sont devenus des
lieux de non droit deviennent pas de
fait des lieux où le où la où le droit
doit doit exister et que toutes ces
personnes parfois qui sont connues des
de je dirais de de de la justice connu
des forces de l'ordre et bien que ces
personnes soient quand on a une
suspicion quand il y a je dirais des
presque des des preuves qui sont des
preuves en lien avec de l'information
qui a été portée à la police et bien que
ces personnes fassent l'objet de
d'interpellation de contrôle vérifier ce
qu'elles font d'où ils tiennent leur
revenu parce qu'ils vivent à grand frais
et tout monde voit ces personnes vivre à
grand frais et personne ne s'interroge
de la provenance de ces fonds à mon avis
ce sont les moyens je le dis je le
répète il faut qu'il y ait plus de
moyens plus de gendarmes de policiers
sur le terrain et puis de la
surveillance en lié avec le je dirais un
niveau de vie que personne ne comprend
et qui donne l'impression que ces
personnes vivent dans
l'impunité très bien bien écoutez je
vous remercie en ce qui me concerne
monsieur le Président j'en ai terminé de
mes questions merci monsieur le
Président et
[Musique]
très très utile intervention et très
utile contenu pour notre pour notre
travail de commission d'enquête
peut-être qu'on peut passer la parole à
Monsieur Jean-Philippe courtois qui
était en voiture que c'est et puis que
Monsieur Jocelin sapoti terminera nos
échanges monsieur
courtois Conn écoutez monsieur SAP vous
prenez le rel n pas connecté si vous le
voulez bien monsieur le président
bon rebonjour tout le monde euh oui donc
je vais pas reproendre ce qu'a dit
Monsieur vanfil sur le fait que nous
soyons une île
passoire où à la fois on a le
narcotrafic donc le trafic bien sûr la
drogue et toutes sortes de drogues des
armes et aussi l'immigration clandestine
et
sexuelle c'est une réalité
et cela CR chez nous une économie je
dirais pas seulement une économie
parallèle nos î ce sont des îes qui
jusqu'à maintenant résistent un T de
chômage à de chiffres parce qu'il a
toujours eu une économie parallèle sauf
que cette économie parallèle avant bien
que illégal rest dans des secteur qui
éta des
secteurs on va dire lgau aujourd'hui
l'économie parallèle est dans le
secteurel
et que nous avons une vraie économie de
la criminalité qui s organisé à partir
de cela mais je vous dis vraie économie
de la criminalité
euh c'est c'est c'est devenu quasiment
je pourrais vous dire automatique
aujourd'hui le recrutement des jeunes
comme ça se fait à Marseille comme a dit
d'ailleurs mon collègue PFIL comme ça se
fait dans voilà certaines grandes villes
de France où le crime est organisé chez
nous c'est devenu cela aujourd'hui et et
et et et nos jeunes sont recrutés euh ce
qui est plus grave je dirais même pas
depuis le lycée depuis le collège depuis
le collège on trouve des jeunes qui sont
déjà des vendeurs d'arbres il sont déjà
des vendeurs d'arbres et qui circulle
avec des vous me parlez de l'expérience
de Mare que je suis ben il y a 3
semaines de cela même pas 15 jours de
cela voilà ma police municipale qui a
arrêté des braqueurs armé des jeunes de
14 15 ans et quand moi je metne une
petite enquête ils me disent qu'ils
peuvent avoir un fusil pour 300 €. ils
peuvent avoir un revolver pour 50 €.
donc ça veut dire que quelque chose euh
euh euh là nous dépasse complètement et
que nos communes sont de vrai passepoir
à ce niveau-là il y a des zones qui sont
beaucoup plus impliqués euh notamment
sur gosier wat concernant euh gosier
Point à Pitre euh concernant le trafic
sexuel là il se passe des choses pour
voilà on noserait même pas passer là des
fois le soir voilà selon ce ce qu'on
pourrait voir entendre tellement
effectivement
ça ça bouillonne dans tous les sens donc
c'est c'est vraiment un sujet qui nous
nous inquiète j'ai fait une intervention
il y a 2 ans cela lors du congrès des ma
pour dire que nous ma nous n'étions pas
suffisamment impliqués dans la lutte
contre ces trois types de trafic euh
trafic de drogue euh trafic d'armes et
euh l'entrée dans ce nos territoire euh
de personnes de manière illégale et
surtout le tourisme enfin pas le
tourisme le le le l'économie du
sexe nous travaillons de concert avec la
police municipe avec la police pour ceux
qui sont en zone de police très très
bien et j'ajoute même j'oute même très
très bien il l'a dit avec pour ceux qui
sont en zone de de
gendarmerie seulement nous n'avons qu'un
contact avec les douaniier et ça les
douanier l'avait très mal pris quand je
l'avais dit mais c'est une réalité c'est
une réalité euh autant aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui sont en zone de police et pour
ceux qui sont en zone de gendarmerie il
y a des relations euh fréquentes des
remontées d'informations il y a des
échanges il y a même un travail qui est
fait en commun euh dernièrement bon ben
ma police municipale s'est uni avec la
gendarmerie euh et c'est pas la première
fois et voilà pour arrêter euh des
bqueurs ou autres mais nous n'avons
aucun contact aucune relation avec euh
avec avec la doine et pourtant toutes
nos communes ont des côtes qui donne sur
la
mer on peut entrer partout sauf en
Guadeloupe il y a que la commune de
Saint-Claude qui n'a pas accès à la mer
toutes nos communes ont accès à la mer
moi je ne MVE chez moi j'ai découvert
dernièrement ben ils ont organisé la
mangve et que à l'intérieur de la
mangrove il y a de la navigation chose
que que que je ne savais pas et et je
suis sûr que ce n'est pas une navigation
saine donc euh oui c'est un vrai
problème chez nous et c'est un problème
qui
à la
fois pose
effectivement la la la question de la
lutte contre cette économie parallèle
qui est uneéconomie du crime mais pose
un autre problème sérieux c'est que
notre jeunesse aujourd'hui est une
jeunesse qui est gravement en danger par
rapport à cela parce que elle ne d pas
seulement elle consomme aussi donc elle
d elle consomme les rglements de compte
se font essentiellement entre les petits
revendeurs et là monsieur panfil l'a dit
c'est toutes les semaines que nous avons
des règlements de compte avec des jeunes
qui
s'entretent avec des jeunes qui
s'entretuent et ça c'est catastrophique
bon ensuite ces armes sont utilisées
pour aller braquer et pour aller braquer
effectivement des personnes qui
ne sont pas dans le trafic ou autre mais
qui sont des des victimes innocentes
comme ça a été le cas chez moi il y a 3
semaines c'était desj le 14 15 ans qui
ont qui ont voilà cassé trois maisons
armé la chance qu'on a eu c'est que bon
les les propriétaires n'était pas là ce
jour-là mais ça pourrait être dramatique
des jeunes de 14 15 ans c'est des jeunes
qui armé qui ne peuvent pas se maîtriser
certainement face à un danger qui
pourrait facilement tirer blesser tuer
voilà personne totalement
innocente nous nous pensons que euh euh
nous Mair euh il faut
il faudrait que nous ayons comment ça se
fait avec la la
avec la police nationale comme ça se
fait avec la gendarmerie une autre
relation avec la douane sur la lutte
contre les armes la drogue et
l'immigration clandestine et surtout
celle qui est liée bien sûr à l'économie
du sexe mais je pense qu'il faut aller
plus loin c'est tellement grave ce qui
se passe chez nous
et compte tenu du fait que nous soyons
des îles et encore plus grave pour la
Guadeloupe parce que la Guadeloupe c'est
un archipel o vous avez l'île principale
de la Guadeloupe mais vous avez aussi la
désigrade particulièrement Marie
gallante qui
est voilà d'après ce qu'on entend l'une
des îles les plus utilisées par les
trafiquants et les
saintes il y a de î TER de haut Terre de
Bas nos territoires sont des territoires
qui voilà qui sont totalement ouverts à
ce genre de trafic
mais nous avons quand même la chance
d'être le petit territoire et
avec les moyens technologiques qui
existent aujourd'hui on pourrait mieux
contrôler et mieux surveiller no
territoirees mais pour ça il faut avoir
la volonté politique de le faire et
vraiment se donner les moyens monsieur
panfil l'a dit il a raison la première
chose qu'il nous faut ce sont des moyens
humains et je dis aussi des moyens
technologiques il y a la technologie qui
permet de détecter euh euh les les
bateaux d'une certaine taille euh de
détecter les les les Canau d'une
certaine taille et et et de pouvoir
intervenir rapidement très rapidement
quand effectivement ces navirl sont
détectés aux alentours de de de de de
nos îles je pense que ça c'est
nécessaire donc ça c'est c'est les
moyens qu'il faut mettre en plus du fait
voilà qu'il faut une autre relation avec
les servicees de la douane il faut aussi
ça et puis euh la troisème proposition
que je ferais elle est peut-être un peu
osée elle est peut-être un peu poussée
je pense qu'elle est nécessaire à une
situation de crise comme celle-là moi je
pense que il faudrait mettre sous une
seule
autorité c'est là c'est là où est le
problème à mon avis à la fois les
services er les services de gendarmerie
et les services de police nationale
contre le narcotrafic contre les
l'entrée des armes et contre
aussi euh les personnes qui arrivent
clandestinement une organisation qui
serait une organisation adaptée à nos
territoires nous nous disons voilà dans
le cadre effectivement de l'adaptation
euh de la de la simplification aussi euh
des des règles et des procédures une
seule autorité qui gérit tout ça une
seule autorité et cette autorité là pour
tre une pour être une autorité euh à la
fois pour qu'il a de la cohérence la
concordance sur nos deux îles
Guadeloupe et
Martinique et qui pourrait euh à mon
avis être beaucoup plus efficace que ce
qui se fait actuellement là et il
faudrait trouver la formule faudrait
trouver comment mettre ça en place mais
une autorité qui serait en charge de la
surveillance de nos côes voilà et et ça
peut
être un super préfet chargé de CL euh ça
peut être délégué ministériel je ne sais
pas mais qui aurait autorité à la fois
sur la Douine sur la gendarmerie et sur
la police nationale sur la question
uniquement de la surveillance de nos
côtes et et et de la lutte contre tous
ces trafic là voilà la proposition que
que je fais elle est peut-être une
proposition voilà qui qui qui sort des
clous mais à mon avis il faut savoir
pousser effectivement les si on veut
trouver des solutions adaptées à nos
territoires très bien merci monsieur le
Président je vous ai bien entendu quand
vous dites il faudrait qu'il y ait des
contacts plus étroits entre les services
qui sont en charge de la lutte contre le
narcotrafic et les élus locaux
et est-ce que euh en qualité de de
président vous avez constaté la mise en
place de de contrat de sécurité et de
prévention de la délinquence qui était
un peu fait pour ça he pour permettre un
dialogue entre la justice la police la
gendarmerie les douanes les services
fiscaux et les élus et et deuxième
question ce dialogue comment vous
l'imaginez et qu'est-ce qui pourrait
apporter à
l'objectif pour être clair ça veut dire
que vous avez un certain nombre
d'informations que vous avez de la peine
à faire remonter au service ça veut dire
que vous avez vous de votre côté par
votre police municipale ou par la
proximité que vous avez avec la
population vous avez fait un certain
nombre de constats et que vous aimeriez
que ces constats soi gérés par les
services de l'État est-ce que vous
pouvez préciser un
peu à la fois les conséquences de manque
que vous avez constaté et et le bénéfice
que pourra apporter vos
proposition alors premièrement sous ces
contratses contrats existent
en Guadeloupe il y en a je sais pas s'il
y en a dans toutes les communes mais a
plusieurs communes dans ma commune il a
chage et ça fonctionne très bien avec le
procureur avec la gendarmerie la zone de
police avec la police mais il y a pas la
douane n'y sont
pas et je peux vous
dire ça va jusquà faire des commun à
fater des informations non mais je vous
assure que ça fonctionne à faire des
interventions communes ça fonctionne
avec la avec la gendarmerie comme l'a
dit Monsieur PFIL euh ou encore zone ça
fonctionne et ces contrats là fonctionn
mais le problème c'est que c'est comme
si on versait de l'eau dans un dans
dansc parce
que tous ces contrats là fonctionnent en
aval il faut traiter le problème en
amont c'est l'entrée des armes et la
drogue et des personnes de manière
illégale etlicit sur nos territoire qui
pose problème or
aujourd'hui nos gendarmes et nos
policiers ont des résultats ils ont des
résultats ils font tout le temps des
arrestations nous faisons remonter des
informations moi je connais les zones
chez moi dans ma commune et cetera où
euh ça
circule le gignn intervient à ma demande
assez souvent
quand je le demande mais le problème
c'est que c'est en aval ça mais ils vont
intervenir combien de fois comme cela si
on ne on n'arrête pas l'entrer en amont
de ses armes et de la drogue c'est ça le
problème et là il y a rien sur cet
aspect là il y a rien l' dit expliqué et
je dis la même chose on est concordant
làdessus il n a rien et c'est là où ça
pêche nos territoires son sont des
passoir des moyens en aval ça va coûter
encore plus à l'état
ou voilà il faudrait renforcer les
moyens en
amont je pense que il vaut mieux se
dire mettons peut-être un peu plus
aujourd'hui ça nous coûtera beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui de mettre en amont les
moyens mais dans le temps on va gagner
et ça coûtera beaucoup moins à l'état et
on sera beaucoup plus efficace derrière
et nous pourrons nous concentrer sur
autre choses sur à en matière de
tranquillité publique en matière de
lutte collectivisme et cetera
voilà je sais pas si j'ai répondu à vos
deux questions ouis très bien moi je
suis satisfait de de vos réponses qui
nous nous permettront d'insister sur ce
que vous venez de dire en fait pour être
clair vous souhaitez que les services
des douanes sur les côtes soi et en mer
et soit beaucoup plus performant
beaucoup plus efficace et plus de moyens
pour éviter des produits stupéfiants de
de de des armes aussi et et des
clandestins sur votre territoire
exactement et vous voyez on s pas
concerté monsieur pfilmi bien bien qu'on
en discute assez souvent mais on tient
le même discours ce sont des réalités
que nous
vivons vous avez parlé du d'une espèce
de bouquet de d'offre criminelle composé
de d'immigration clandestine
euh fondz notamment sur l'économie du
sexe vous avez parlé des stupéfiants des
armes est-ce que vous vous observez dans
dans la période récente des des
évolutions est-ce que alors en volume en
nature est-ce que ce sont les mêmes
organisations qui portent tout ça à
votre connaissance comment ça se euh
réparti cette cette criminalité
organisée alors ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous nous n'avons pas
d'information sur l'organisation de
cette nous n'avons aucune information
là-dessus par contre les conséquences
nous les voyons et nous les subissons
moi les conséquences je les vois je les
vois dans certains quartiers de chez moi
j'ai la chance bien heureusement euh
d'IR pas beaucoup et d'être circonscrit
dans une toute petite zone de chez moi
mais tout autour de ma commune espèce
d'il ma commune un peu sauvée euh euh
j'ai la commune de bmao j'ai la commune
de Saint- rose euh j'ai la commune de
petitbou qui qui sont trois communes
limitrophes où c'est en grande très
grande augmentation et le problème c'est
que le public concerné de plus en plus
jeune et ce que nous constatons nous
c'est qu'il y a un vrai recoutement de
nos
jeunes comme ça se fait aujourd'hui dans
certaines grandes villes de France comme
Marseille ou autes nos jeunes sont
recrutés depuis le
collège et et et et ça c'est c'est
quelque chose que nous servonsnous nous
savons pas comment ça s'organise nous
n'avons pas les informations mais nous
envoyons les conséquences et les
conséquences sont graves dans les
familles puisque nous nous avons des
remontés qui viennent des familles quand
vous avez des familles qui qui crient au
secours qui viennent voir le maire parce
que le papa ou encore la maman constaté
que son fils était armé chez lui lui n'a
pas d'arme mais il a un fils de 14 15
ans qui est
armé et des fois les familles même sont
désemparé par rapport à cela c'est ça la
situation que nous vivons aujourd'hui
c'est mon expérience de mère qui qui me
permet de connaître ça puisque j'ai les
retours de famille nous avons des
familles en cette difficulté dépvu des
fois même de moyens vous imaginez un
père aujourd'hui qui voudrait
représenter son fils et le fils qui lui
dit écoutez voilà moi je suis armé c'est
ce qui se passe maintenant chez
nous je vous décris les choses tquel
hein donc c'est pour vous dire la
gravité effectivement voilà la
situation pardon est-ce que vous
pourriez je peux rajouter quelque
chose allez-y est-ce que je peux allez-y
monsieur
oui en en en en complément de de ce que
dit Jocelin
sapti vous avez un phénomène qui est un
phénomène aujourd'hui qui est nouveau
c'est celui de de personnes qui sont
totalement
décomplexé vis-à-vis en fait de d'une
criminalité que nous que nous ne
connaissions pas avant dire quand quand
Jos sa petit parle
d'exécution chez nous en Martinique en
Guadeloupe nous ne connaissions pas ce
genre de choses et quand vous avez des
exécutions entre jeunes entre bandes
rivales ce sont des choses que nous ne
connaissions pas et parfois même ce sont
des exécutions qui sont structurées
organisées avec du recroutement de
main-dœuvre qui ne serait pas de la main
d'œuvre comment dire locale c'est une
main-dœuvre qui vient qui exécute
quelque chose et qui s'en va donc c'est
pour illustrer les le sentiment de
passoir que l'on a je commin un fait
délictueux le samedi le dimanche je ne
suis plus là donc la question de la
coopération puisque on n a pas
spécialement parlé surous le principe de
la coopération il y a pas de souci je
pense que aujourd'hui de manière très
unanime tous les responsables politiques
on on ont plaide pour qu'il y ait une
coopération économique dans nos espaces
de vie de sorte que le je dirais que le
dans les bassins de vie et en
l'occurrence le bassin de vie caraïbéen
qu'il y ait vraiment une coopération par
contre
euh le le le grand banditisme
aujourd'hui également fait de la
coopération criminelle de sorte que vous
avez des personnes qui sortent de
territoire limitrophe au nutre je veux
pas euh euh je dirais pointer du doigt
et citer des noms mais que ce soit
saintelucie à côté ou la Dominique de
l'autre côté vous avez une je dirais
l'entrée dans nos territoires et en
l'occurrence territoires français de
personnes qui sont originaires donc de
ces îles anglaises et qui ont une
posture vis-à-vis des martiniquins ou
des Guadeloupéens parfois qui est une
posture extrêmement violente donc moi je
vous dis les personnes sont décomplexées
ce qui ce que nous n'avions pas avant
euh Jocelin a dit vous avez des jeunes
qui sont recrutés d'argent facile mais
ça c'est pas nouveau c'est quelque chose
qui se développe de plus en plus et puis
tout à l'heure on a parlé des des
contrats locaux de sécurité moi vous
savez un contrat local de sécurité pour
moi n'a pas vocation à euh
à intervenir ou regarder ce qui se passe
en terme de narcotrafic et je fais bien
la distinction entre le la recherche
d'un apaisement d'une situation de vie
que ce soit chez les bailleurs dans
l'espace de vie quotidien collectif où
là effectivement le le le le contrat
local de sécurité peut jouer totalement
son rôle par contre quand on change
d'échelle et qu'on est sur une échelle
du grand banditisme et de la criminalité
euh pour moi CLS CLS ou un CLSPD d' est
complètement dépassé par ce genre de de
situation et effectivement nous avons
dans dans beaucoup de communes
d'ailleurs euh nous avons travaillé en
Martinique sur la signature de contrat
territorial de sécurité et dans le cadre
de ce contrat territorial de sécurité
effectivement nous avons mis les élus
nous avons mis la gendarmerie la police
nationale euh et les bailleurs sociaux
effectivement autour de la table pour
aller pour trouver des solutions qui
seraient des solutions et qui permettrai
effectivement de d'améliorer le
quotidien de vie des gens euh mais je
pense que avec Jocelin on est
unanimement d'accord c'est que les
moyens technologique la surveillance des
côtes les radars autour de nos
territoires pour identifier l'égofast et
puis des entrées intempestives je pense
que c'est ce sont ces moyenslà et puis
il y a une chose je l'ai dit en début de
mon intervention quand la la douane
communique quand la l'armée limite la
police euh communique sur les prises
importantes de je dirais de drogues qui
sont faites euh autour de l'île autour
de nos îles il y a également une
communication qui est faite notamment
sur les mules parce que je vois parfois
des images de ce qui peut se passer en
Guyane de de personnes qui sont
interpellées à l'aéroport ài quand elles
arrivent le nombre de mules aujourd'hui
qui sont comment dire dans les avions
parce que il y a effectivement une
surveillance un peu plus accrue sur le
le trafic en mer je pense que là aussi
sur les moyens qui doivent être déployer
il faut que l'on puisse comment dire en
terme de communication expliquer aux
gens à la fois les risques en matière de
santé publique pour leur propre santé le
le risque de qu'ils prennent en étant
des mules et singulièrement les
personnes qui sont situation de pauvreté
et de précarité qui voit un élément
effectivement de sortir de de leur
situation donc moi je pense que tous les
moyens doivent être déployés Joselin l'a
dit euh je reprécise les choses
notamment sur les personnes qui sont en
situation de précarité pour permettre
que progressivement mais de manière
rapide et bien qu'on puisse ne pas
continuer à voir une société être en
délicissence avec une un tau de
précarité et de pauvreté qui facilite et
bien le l'orientation vers ce ces
situations de crimininalité extrême
merci beaucoup monsieur panfil je
propose qu'on passe la parole à à
Jean-Philippe courtois
euh qui ne l'a pas eu jusque là et puis
peut-être que je poserai une question à
vous trois je sais pas si monsieur
courtois nous entend sur la criminalité
forcée parce que tout à l'heure on a
parlé de la la corruption euh monsieur
panfil nous disait qu'il y avait pas de
enfin vous n'aviez pas eu écho de ce
type de de pratique mais peut-être sur
la criminalité forcée je pensais aux
jeunes est-ce qu'ils le font tous par à
trait de l'argent facile ou est-ce qu'il
y a parfois une dimension de contrainte
monsieur courtois je vous laisse
ouvrir merci monsieur le Président
bonjour à tous envocaz qualité euh je
commencerai effectivement par vous dire
que toutes les conditions en fait sont
sont réunis he pour que N nos
territoires soi en grande difficulté et
on peut même s'interroger sur la volonté
réelle qui pourrait exister pour nous
sortir donc de ce mal
puisque nous le voyons régulièrement
encore récemment de jeunes qui ont été
tués sur une plage puisqu'ils ont
rencontré donc un personnage donc addict
euh au stupéfiants donc c'est vous dire
que nous sommes arrivés à un stade où en
Guadeloupe on hésite à 10 fois avant de
sortir de chez soi le soir ça a un
impact forcément aussi donc au niveau
donc des euh des collectivités puisqueen
ma qualité de de maire sur ma première
mandature
euh je suis forcément donc très
interpellé par les les familles quand on
voit donc les situations qui dégénèrent
dans des quartiers résidentiels euh
encore récemment j'ai été interpellé
parce qu'il y a eu donc des des coups de
feu dans une résidence euh encore
récemment connu pour être calme et quand
on on interroge un peu donc les les
jeunes de la zone donc ce sont donc là
des des conflits autour donc de de la
vente de drogue de la vente d'armes
euh on constate aussi toujours pour
rester sur l'aspect proprement donc de
la ville donc c'est un impact aussi sur
les finances puisque nous nous devons
donc mobiliser doublement donc notre
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale pour
pouvoir accompagner ces famille puisque
vous comprendrez qu'il y a là aussi donc
problème liés donc à problème sociétal
euh lié donc aux difficulté que
rencontre ces ces foyers pour la plupart
malheureusement donc monoparental donc
ce qui rajoute aussi donc à des
difficultés d'encadrement et d'éducation
pour pour certains mais ce qui impacte
là aussi donc le budget puisqu'il faut
que nous puissions créer des conditions
ne serait-ce que pour accompagner donc
euh ceci créer des conditions aussi pour
que ces jeunes soient dans les
meilleures options pour pouvoir
poursuivre des études et donc les
éloigner le plus que possible de la rue
multiplier donc la mise en place de de
chantiers d'insertion ça aussi ça ça
coûte la collectivité même si ce n'est
pas euh l'une de ces compétences
première il est aussi aujourd'hui euh
d'usage que nous puissions donc
installer donc la vidéo protection donc
avec le coût euh d'installation de
gestion de formation des hommes encore
une fois que doit supporter elle seul la
collectivité à capester bot donc nous
sommes aussi donc dans une dynamique de
devoir armer aujourd'hui donc notre
police municipale donc celle qui hier
était vu donc essentiellement comme une
police de proximité maintenant si elle
veut pouvoir répondre à l'ensemble de de
ces missions on est contraint donc
maintenant de réfléchir à à les arméses
pour pouvoir aussi donc les protéger et
dissuader aussi celles et ceux qui sont
en face et on en a parlé aussi donc
grandement tout à l'heure sur le fait
que la boisou soit une passeport je vous
DIRIS que capester Bellot de par son
positionnement géographique et la porte
d'entrée euh de tous ces trafics de mon
domicile j'ai une vue euh parfaite sur
la mer et sur cette zone qui donne entre
Marie Galante qui a été identifiée comme
étant la la porte d'entrée euh de Mass
et l'île de la Dominique donc qui se
situe entre la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique et il s'avère que nous
n'ayons en réalité qu'une seule frégate
de taille équipée réellement pour
pouvoir couvrir donc la zone maritime de
la Martinique et de la Guadeloupe donc
c'est aussi simple que cela c'est-à-dire
que de mon domicile je vois cette
frégate quitter donc la Martinique et
donc faire le contour de l'île de de la
Dominique et dès le moment où elle
pointe son nez entre la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique toute navigation est
quasiment arrêté entre la Dominique et
la Guadeloupe donc c'est vous dire que
nous avons simplement un système qui
dissuade pendant quelques heures les
différents trafics et qui reprennent une
fois que celle-ci a quitté les euh les
les EAU donc nous sommes livrés à
nous-mêmes livrés à nous-même avec des
quantités astronomiques de drogue qui
sont donc qui inondent notre territoire
donc avec cette jeunesse qui qui est
perdue nous avons aussi on ne dit pas
suffisamment euh des adultes qui sont
aussi donc maintenant addictes à ces
produits donc comment éduquer ses
enfants comment transmettre des valeurs
quand soi-même on a donc déjà ce type
d'handicap euh quand on a aussi donc sur
ces bateaux donc des armes qui arrivent
en quantité est-ce qu'on va devoir
continuer à se satisfaire uniquement du
dispositif déposer les armes quand on
sait quand on qu'on regarde les euh les
éléments qui sont qui sont traduits euh
ce sont les chasseurs qui déposent donc
les les armes qu'il n'utilisent plus ou
celles et ceux qui ont arrêté donc ce
type d'activité qui les amemmène mais
c'est dire que les armes qui rentrent
sur le territoire donc par ce circuit
euh en réalité ne ne retrouve
euh des mains je dirais euh de de Just
d'agents donc de de sécurité que très
rarement donc après des méfaits et de
l'autre on a aussi donc ce problème donc
d'immigration clestine qui qui arrive
aussi avec son lot de violence l'OT de
violence donc lié donc à ces différents
trafics puisquil s'agit donc de
personnes qui euh malheureusement
quelquefois sont recherchés chez elles
ou qui viennent avec la volonté donc
d'amasser assez rapidement donc des des
fonds donc avec ce circuit parallèle qui
arrive aussi avec cet esclavage sexuel
qui est imposé donc à certaines femmes
et en bout de chaîne nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui donc avec des
réseaux qui sont bien organisés sur nos
différents TER territoire euh avec des
gants qui sont maintenant établis donc
dans sur certaines zones de notre
territoire qui portent leur couleur avec
que ce soit des bandanas que ce soit
avec des T-Shirts donc c'est vous dire
qu'il ne se cache même plus des des
autorités et j'ose le dire aussi hein
que depuis qu'effectivement que des
actions donc fortes ont commencé à être
initié du côté de la Guiane que nous
retrouvons euh une pression qui qui
double sur notre territoire puisque les
les chiffres le le démon tant avec le
euh la drogue qui a été donc retrouvée
donc récemment que ce soit en Martinique
et en Guadeloupe mais aussi avec ces
fait d'armes qui ne cesse d'augmenter
puisquon le voit avec un petit
territoire comme la Guadeloupe avec plus
de 50 tués par mafeu cela doit nous
questionner et c'est dans ce cadre il
est aussi indispensable que l'État que
le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités vis-à-vis de cette
compétence qui est régalienne puisqu'on
ne peut pas imaginer que la seule
sécurité donc des administrés donc va se
résumer donc comme je disait au disposi
de déposer des armes ou des CLSPD qui
sont réalité là pour mettre en place des
activités donc dans dans les quartiers
des activités pour retrouver du lien
voilà mais le vrai problème de fond
celui où il faut donc maintenant
démontrer que la force reste et
l'autorité doit rester donc aux hommes
donc en uniforme nous sommes là je DIRIS
pas suffisamment bien servi sur sur le
territoire et il est indispensable que
nous soyons conscients pour pouvoir
régler les problèmes de drogue que vous
allez retrouver dans le 93 ou dans
d'autres euh quartiers je dirais dis
sensibles c'est parce qu'il faut que
nous puissions dès le départ stopper
donc euh ces ces couloirs
d'approvisionnement et cela va passer
par une sécurisation des côtes de la
Guad de la Martinique en donnant les
moyens que ce soit technique humains
mais aussi matériel aux forces de police
sur nos territoires et surtout que nous
puissions retrouver ce sentiment de
sécurité chez nous
voilà pour mon prop
introductif très bien merci pour cette
intervention très très complète et
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques pistes
d'amélioration on a bien
entendu vous souhaitez plus
d'intervention douanière plus
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
maritime pour éviter l'approvisionnement
des îles
mais dans votre commune par exemple
quelle suggestion pourriez-vous faire
pour que l'on contrôle mieux le trafic
au quotidien le deal de drogue et
surtout comment est-ce qu'on peut
contrôler les flux financiers qui
résultent de ces trafics est-ce que vous
auriez quelques suggestions à nous
transmettre
suggestion la première ce sont des des
moyens des moyens humains pu ce que euh
j'ai la chance d'avoir un territoire
avec cette spécificité d'avoir une zone
gendarmerie et une zone police mais il
est très compliqué aujourd'hui de
pouvoir assurer donc la sécurité des
concitoyens quand nous avons un
commissariat qui est sousdouté en terme
de moyens humain c'est-à-dire que nous
sommes retrouvés à certaine période avec
l'impossibilité donc d'avoir des rondes
de nuit ou les jours férier donc vous
comprendrez bien les difficultés que
cela peut engendrer surtout les euh le
soir donc au moment où il y a donc le le
plus de possibilités donc à des m fait
et les jours de fête où les conditions
sont réunies pour que certains donc
puissent s'adonner à certaines dérives
donc ça c'est déjà une première réalité
c'est-à-dire que nous manquons de moyens
humains pour pouvoir assurer donc le
service de l'autre il faut une meilleure
coordination donc sur sur le territoire
puisque si je vous le dis que moi en
qualité de citoyen assis je dirais
devant ma maison je vois ces bateaux je
peux les identifier je les vois
tellement souvent que je peux quasiment
euh dire qu'il a une activité
touristique de celui qui qui aurait une
activité je dirais quelque peu plus
sombre donc c'est dire qu'il est
nécessaire de pouvoir donner les moyens
pour pouvoir mieux contrôler nos côtes
puisque les points sont identifiés les
lieux où ces gens donc débarquent sont
tellement connus que ce sont quasiment
euh 90 % des cas les voisins qui
interpellent donc la gendarmerie ou la
police pour leur dire qu'il y a donc là
un débarquement donc de clandestin et
euh et et de et de valisettes donc c'est
dire que derrière il faut que nous puiss
donc maintenant à soir et ça je peux
comprendre que cela ne ne puisse pas
forcément perdurer dans le temps mais à
un moment il va falloir une opération
coup de point pour pouvoir sécuriser nos
côtes et faire en sorte que la peur
change de camp on ne peut pas imaginer
qu'en bordure je prends l'exemple du du
port de bananier que passer une certaine
heure que les citoyens se sentent
obligés de fermer leurs portes et leurs
fenêtre pour ne pas être témoin et donc
ne pas être des cibles euh à la suite
alors qu'en réalité ce seront les
trafiquants qui devraient avoir peur de
pouvoir se montrer là comme ça au grand
jour à proximité d'une d'une route
nationale donc aussi bien passante que
visible de tous et cela il est
nécessaire donc de pouvoir renforcer les
moyens et ça je le dis bien ce n'est pas
un problème je dirais d'échange de
communication avec les autorités puis
qu' des très très bonne la capacité j'ai
régulièrement donc le le chef donc de la
caserne de la gendarmerie comme celui
donc du commissariat de police de
capestire mais derrière il faut que
qu'il puisse avoir les moyens
nécessaires pour pouvoir bloquer ce type
d'action euh aussi créer les conditions
que sur des territoires qui sont
identifiés comme ention cap Bello c'est
clair nous nous faisons partie des
communes les plus représentées dans le
milieu carcéral donc c'est dire qu'il y
a une difficulté on ne peut pas imaginer
que ce soit uniquement au travers des
actions de la politique de la ville de
la mise en place des de centres sociaux
d'espace de vie initié par la
municipalité que nous allons retisser du
lien il y a un moment aussi il faut
qu'il y ait des opérations coup de point
pour aller sur ces zones de de trafic
ces zones où s'installe donc cette
petite délinquence pour aussi rappeler à
qui est l'autorité et ça malheureusement
on l'a pas suffisamment on a des
contrôles autoroutiers donc comme là à
la veille donc des des fêtes de Noël on
va voir tous les ronds-points qui vont
être bleus comme on dit mais on n'aura
pas ces lieux de vente de drogues de
vente d'armes de petites délinquances où
on va avoir donc des opérations coup de
point pour pouvoir faire peur le
Président sapoti il a dit tout à l'heure
nous avons régulièrement donc des
actions initiées par le le gignn ou le
GPN mais ça ça arrive toujours après mes
Fas je pense qu'il faut là aussi que
nous puissions revoir la la stratégie
avec une meilleure gouvernance ça peut
être aussi donc la mise en place d'un
d'un préfet donc dédié uniquement à ces
problématiques pas à la sécurité de
façon globale comme nous l'avons
aujourd'hui donc avec le le secrétaire
général mais avec avec un sous-préfet
qui aurait lui pour objectif de régler
ces ces problèmes donc sur not
territoire et avec des objectifs qui
soient clairement posés avec les
municipalités pour ensemble donc des des
solutions qui soient minucieuses qui
soient identifié par rapport à la
spécificité de chaque territoire et
surtout qui a en bout de course puisse
détabiliser les différents réseaux
écoutez merci ce propos était très clair
très limpide
euh on est très heureux de vous avoir eu
les uns et les
autres pour répondre à questions euh
comme nous avons une succession de
d'auditions cet après-midi je vous
propose qu'on en reste là euh une
proposition de de d'intervention écrite
vous a été faite hein si vous souhaitez
préciser certains éléments que vous avez
développé aujourd'hui à l'oral par écrit
nous en serons très satisfaits donc
merci beaucoup messieurs bon courage sur
votre territoire et puis euh merci
encore de votre participation à bientôt
au revoir merci merci au revoir à
bientôt au revoir à bientôt
merci à bientôt
bientôt